today on the matt welsh show as the jury
in the chauvin trial gives the violent
mob
exactly what it demanded another police
shooting has led to more protests and
claims of systemic racism and policing
the problem is that the victim
in this case quote unquote victim was
shot while trying to stab someone
so we'll have more on that case and the
shove in trial today also speaking of
the shoving case
nancy pelosi officially canonizes george
floyd as our culture's new
christ figure i mean literally that's
what she did in our daily cancellation
we'll deal
with complaints that a children's
cartoon about dogs
fails to portray racial diversity how
can you have racial diversity among
cartoon dogs well we'll talk tackle that
and much more today on the matte wall
show
so i had planned of course to begin
today talking about the verdict
in the chauvin trial a verdict that was
reached by the jury hours after the
president united states went on tv and
publicly called for a guilty verdict
also shortly after the mayor of the city
demanded a conviction and only a day
after one of the most prominent members
of congress flew from dc to minneapolis
to inflame the already violent mob it
was a verdict reached by a jury in the
same city that had been devastated by
riots last year because of this case
and where even worse riots would have
happened had they returned anything but
the verdict they did return
a verdict reached in a trial that could
have been moved to a different city and
could have involved the sequestering of
the jury for the whole trial but that
but it wasn't and didn't even aside from
the facts of the case
facts which very clearly amount to
reasonable doubt
on all charges in my opinion rather than
a conviction on all charges which is
what the jury decided
but even aside from those facts the
public pressure the location the refusal
by the judge to take any steps
whatsoever
to address any of these issues all of
that is enough to call this a
fundamentally unfair and unjust trial
and one in which the verdict cannot be
trusted i mean
moving the trial's location and
sequestering the jury these are tools
that a a judge has in his toolbox
if this trial didn't call for those
things
then what trial in history ever has
this is why this is a decision which
should be appealed and retried but it
may never get that far because
almost everyone in this country
especially
in positions of leadership including in
the court system is too afraid of the
mob to do the right thing
there should have been a mistrial
declared at various points along the way
but certainly when maxine water showed
up
and did what she did that should have
been mistrial
but courage is in short supply in this
country though we've never needed it
more
there's never been so little of it but
as i said this is the topic that i was
going to open the show with we'll talk
more about that
later that was until a new case a new
protest
a new blm martyr was appointed right as
the guilty
verdict in the chauvin case was read blm
protesters
were descending on columbus ohio in
response to a police shooting
that had happened just hours earlier now
as we've seen over and over again
the narrative takes shape solidifies uh
metastasizes like a cancerous tumor
rapidly i mean within minutes within
seconds now
and this time as almost always the
narrative was that
the victim 16 year old micaiah bryant
was innocent unarmed helpless not a
threat to anyone
and had been gunned down randomly by
police police showed up and just shot
her dead that's basically what we were
told
activists and media journalists but i
repeat myself took the words of the
supposed witnesses and the supposed
victims family
and ran with it as gospel truth as they
always do
before any other facts here's here's the
point we're at now before any other
facts about this case had circulated
already this video clip of mikaya
bryant's mother
now she was out in front of cameras
uh right away right away within minutes
within within hours at least
and before we knew anything else this
was the clip making the rounds and this
is what
established the narrative uh here's what
mikhail
bryant's mother said let's listen makaya
was named after a male prophet in a
bible
she was a very loving peaceful
little girl she was 16 years old she was
an honorable student
and makaya had a motherly
nature about her she promoted peace
and that's something that i want to
always be remembered
loving motherly and honorable student
she promoted peace
that's what her mother says her mother
we should know
did not have legal custody of her
daughter micaiah was in foster care
even more important to note the loving
and peaceful micaiah was actually shot
by cops while in the process of trying
to murder somebody with a knife
the same day as the shooting only hours
after
after the shooting happened actually
columbus police held a press conference
and uh you know usually it like takes a
couple of days but now we're at a point
now where it just
they they put the body cam footage out
right away
even that is it's not quick enough if
you can't get it out within seconds it's
not gonna be fast enough
to get out in front of the narrative so
this is a few hours later
still not fast enough but they showed
the body cam footage and explained the
context of the shooting and
let's watch that now 71 legion
lane the information was that a caller
said females were there trying to stab
them and put their hands on them
dispatchers tried to obtain information
about weapons but were unable to gather
that information
officers were dispatched at 4 36 and
arrived at 4
44. we will play the first video
in real time
hey
there's there's the body camouflage so
the cops were called to the scene
because someone was trying to stab
somebody else
that's all they know police officer
arrives
sees a woman wielding a large knife
appears to be a butcher's knife or steak
knife that you get from your kitchen
i mean this is the point is this is no
pocket knife this is a large knife
suspect attacks one other woman and
pushes her to the ground
and then she goes after someone else the
girl in pink and the body cam footage
mikaya pins the girl in pink against the
car
raises the knife and is in the process
of trying to stab her
when the officer given no other choice
from his perspective opens fire
makaya was not unarmed she had a knife
she was not peaceful at least in that
video she was trying to stab someone
these details matter at least they
matter to those of us who are honest and
rational though our club is
small and losing members by the day
the full facts of the case as they've
now been revealed facts which
absolutely without any shadow of a doubt
vindicate the police officer and reveal
him to be not just justified but heroic
acting to save someone's life but of
course that doesn't matter none of it
matters
still the cop is accused not just of
murder but of racist murder
this is part of the fact that he was
firing not even to defend himself but to
defend the life of another black girl
he shot a black girl to stop her from
killing another black girl
and that makes him a homicidal racist
there's no reasoning with this thinking
because there's no thinking involved the
left needs
this is what the left needs to know they
need to know only two things two data
points
did the police kill someone and was that
person black if so it was racism every
time without exception
now let's let's really consider the
position
this officer was in he's called to the
scene
he finds a black girl trying to gut
another black girl with a butcher's
knife
if he shoots he's racist if he doesn't
shoot
and the other black girl gets stabbed
and killed right in front of him
he'll be accused of not acting to save
the life of that
black child so if he saves the black
girl's life
then he's guilty of not valuing the
assailant's life
he doesn't save her life he's guilty of
not valuing the victim's life
and because they're both black then no
matter what he does he's
not valuing the life of one or the other
of the black people involved
no matter what he does he loses no
matter what he does
he's already condemned simply for
arriving to the scene
the moment he is there wearing that
badge he's done
there's nothing he can do no option he
can avail himself of
that would not lead to accusations of
racism
of course you're always going to get the
monday morning quarterback
why didn't you use a taser
when someone is in the process
they've got the knife like this and
they're in the process of trying to stab
a taser is by no means guaranteed to
stop that from happening
you could shoot them with the taser and
they're still going to get that stab in
they can get multiple blows in certainly
at least one
i could a knife that size a blade that
size
could ev just one stab placed in the
right place
could very easily kill somebody
so if he had done that if he just pulled
the taser out uh tried to use a taser
and um and it wasn't enough and
and the the the girl was stabbed to
death
then what would the activists be saying
you know what they'd be saying they'd be
saying oh
yeah well now you use a taser because uh
because it's not important enough to you
to use lethal force to save this black
child's life
that's what they would say and we all
know it
so there's no option except for one
perhaps here's the other option if
you're a cop
don't take the call you know there was
some static over the radio you didn't
hear it oops these things happen
go grab a coffee instead stay out of it
let whatever's gonna happen happen the
other members of the community
there you see him in the video there
appear to be some adults there as well
they don't seem too concerned about
these kids lives anyway they're just
standing around watching
like a night fight between teenagers as
a spectator sport
so let the violence happen stay far away
from it
if parents don't want to raise their
children if communities don't want to
care for themselves then let them reap
what they sow
what we know for sure is that if the
cops had done that if mckay had simply
been
had simply been allowed to stab the
other girl to death
and no cop was in the vicinity that we'd
never hear a word about it
blm wouldn't care you wouldn't have
people on the media in the media weeping
and wailing oh no another black life
taken i'm so distraught they wouldn't be
saying that
any of that at all they wouldn't say a
damn word about it
there'd be no protest no outrage no
morning
because there'd be no political or
ideological benefit to any of that
the left needs the cops involved for
that
so the real way for the police to avoid
the lose-lose situation is to avoid the
situation completely
and yet you know they still respond to
the call
they still show up to the scene it turns
out lots of cops really do care
about protecting and serving even
protecting and serving communities
that wouldn't spit on them if they were
on fire in fact they probably lit the
fire
now cops aren't superhuman they aren't
superheroes they aren't perfect they
aren't saints nobody is but
i can't imagine why any of them would
still be on the job
at this point if they didn't at least
care about helping and protecting people
why else would you be there now what
other motivation
could you possibly have
sadly for them they're doing that job in
a culture that
doesn't care about justice and truth
doesn't care about the rule of law
doesn't care about human life except
when it can be used
as i talk about all the time human life
in this culture
all human life black or white
is a commodity it's something to be used
if you can't use it then you just throw
it away like it like it doesn't exist
we do that in the womb
just wait we call it in the womb if if a
life is taken in the womb
we call it medical waste throw it in a
medical waste dumpster out back
of the abortion clinic
so life only has value when it can be
used
and when it comes to black lives
in the city from the media's perspective
and our culture perspective
they have value after the life has
already been taken
if it was taken in a circumstance that's
politically advantageous
to the cultural powers that be
that's the culture we live in a culture
governed not by mob rule
okay let's get that straight this this
is not mob rule
this is a culture governed by the rule
of leftist elites
who use the mob to affect their ends
and and that has made many things very
difficult to merely live as a normal and
decent person maintaining
your decency insanity amid deterrent is
at times a herculean task for everybody
but to enforce the law in this culture
in this environment
with your life and the lives of others
on the line
that is now almost impossible
now let's get to our five headlines
all right now we can get into some more
about the the derek chovin chauvin
verdict first vice president biden
yesterday vice president biden
uh after weighing in on the case and
calling for a guilty verdict
while the jury was still deliberating
and remember the judge in the case
admonished maxine waters and asked all
political officials to stay out of it
hours later the mayor of minneapolis
gets up says he wants guilty party
and the president united states goes in
front of cameras and says he
he strongly implies that there should be
a guilty verdict
um but after the the verdict was read
he then addressed the nation about the
results of this local murder trial
of course president camilla harris spoke
first and then vice president biden
got up and shared his thoughts about how
all of this relates back to systemic
racism let's listen
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there were systemic races that's a stain
on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma the pain the
exhaustion
and black and brown americans experience
every single
day systemic racism no
i'm i am still to this point
waiting for some i've heard over and
over and over again
that this case it's just it's assumed
it's like it's self-evident
that of course this case is uh all about
race and racism
even some so-called conservatives on
social media after the verdict
we're celebrating it as a as a as a
victory for
for racial justice and you know
that qualifier is important because the
shogun verdict has nothing to do with
justice doesn't have anything to do with
justice as we have traditionally
understood it um
it's not justice in the you know the way
that
that courts are supposed to be enacting
justice
but it is racial justice
and it's racial justice because for the
simple fact that derek chovan's white
and he's accused of killing black men
whether he did or not but and
and um and as we were told by the media
many times
during the trial and before it that this
is not just about derek chovin the
entire country is on trial
all of white america is on trial
derek chovin was the the sacrificial
goat
as i've been saying this whole time he's
a sacrificial goat
much much like you know religious
ceremonial practices that date back
thousands of years
he is this sacrificial offering
and the guilt of of white america is
placed on his shoulders and
uh and so you know and when you when you
bring the the sacrificial goat to the
altar
it has to be burned
in sacrifice and it was in this case
and that's why you know i was saying i i
i haven't heard anyone even try to
actually explain
what racism how racism plays into any of
this
pretending for a second for the sake of
argument
that chovin actually is guilty on all
accounts and that we can say that beyond
a reasonable doubt which we can't
but pretending we can okay race
what so you're saying if if
what you go back and watch the body cam
footage and then you
and then you go to the the footage taken
by the uh the
bystanders what part of that do you
think would be different
if if george floyd had a lighter skin
tone
if you had a what was george floyd six
foot five or six 240 pounds
so you've had a six foot six 240 pound
uh convicted felon high on four times
the lethal dose of
fentanyl trying to pass counterfeit
bills
what what what would the police do
differently resisting arrest
saying he can't breathe before he's on
the ground
asking to be put on the ground he does
ask that
they get him into the into the police
car he crawls back out you know
all of that's exactly the same but he's
got lighter skin tone um
they think what what part of it plays
out differently
well of course there's no answering that
question
and it's easier to to blame everything
when you take
racism the concept of racism and you've
expanded it
into the point of meaninglessness
and also whiteness and white supremacy
all of these words can mean anything now
um so there's there's president biden on
on the chiming in for for some reason we
need
an address from the vice president and
the president
on this case as i brought up in the we
did it backstage yesterday and
as i brought up there think back to the
kermit gosnell case
um he was an abortionist in uh
in philadelphia most prolific serial
killer
in american history hundreds of born
children that he killed he also killed
some of his female patients that came to
him
and he was able to do this in a major
american city
for decades and the reason he was able
to do that
is because the government at every level
chose to look the other way so this was
a case that
that implicated the government
you know there were there were hundreds
of of lives taken
hundreds of people deeply affected by it
thousands deeply affected by it
so that was a case of national
significance for all those reasons
but the media totally ignored it
obama in office at the time ignored it
and the reason we were given is that it
was a
a local crime story that was a local
crime story
somehow and the reality is the opposite
that was not a local crime story that
was like that was a a crime
that involves the government this it
actually does involve the system there
were there were
actual systemic failures that led to
this and allowed it to happen
but the shelving case no matter what
else you think about it it's a local
issue
an isolated incident
um all right so more reaction to the
shoving verdict first
uh here's someone on msnbc explaining
why
even though they got everything they
want they're still very very unhappy
shockingly let's listen i actually
always thought that he would be found
guilty because it's sort of a cultural
makeup call
but i'm not happy i'm not pleased i
don't have any sense of satisfaction i
don't think this is a system working
i don't think this is a good thing what
this says to me
is that in order to get a nominal degree
of justice in this country
that a black man has to be murdered on
air viewed by the entire world there
have to be a year's worth of protests
and a
phalanx of other white police officers
to tell one white officer
that he was wrong in order to get one
scintilla of justice
notice okay he's not he's not happy of
course the left we know that they're
never they're never happy
um the revolution continues
and they also assume he says yeah i knew
there'd be a guilty verdict
they assume they're gonna get what they
want and they do most of the time
but you're never gonna be satisfied
that's why i think um
i've always thought the label
progressivism
it fits now you might not like
when you when you think of what what the
left is doing i don't really consider it
progress but it is pr
it's progress in the way that cancer
progresses
in that sort of way it just keeps
moving and infecting and growing
and left-wing progressivism is the same
way never it never
gets to a point where it's satisfied and
says all right i've i've had enough
just keep moving to the next thing keep
moving on
um so he's not happy obviously but
notice how he
he admits basically admits that
this verdict was uh partly the product
of the pressure put on the jury
he says it right there he says that what
we needed to have a year of protests and
all this stuff in order to get that that
that
quote-unquote justice
he's admitting he's admitting that the
jury
at least partially from his perspective
came to this conclusion
because that's what that that's the
pressure that was put on them
aoc had i think we had this clip she had
a similar take let's let's play that
it's not justice and i'll explain to you
why it's not justice
it's not justice because justice
is george floyd going home tonight
to be with his family justice
is adam toledo
getting tucked in by his mom tonight
justice is
when you're pulled over there not being
a gun that's part of that interaction
because you have a headlight out what is
that supposed to refer to
a gun's not part of that interaction
well if you're talking about dante
wright the reason the gun's part of the
interaction is because
you committed armed robbery against a
woman and there was a warrant for your
arrest
and they tried to arrest you and you
resisted that that's how the gun got
involved there
this is not i i will agree though aside
from that last part the rest of it
i sort of agree this is not justice
this verdict is not just because it's
the result of
of pressure
this is this is really it's the death of
the rule of law
where the left knows that you know it
can get someone convicted of murder
if it wants but i thought of all you
know and we could sit here all day
playing the reaction from the left and
the media to the shove and trial
and and most of it is exactly what you
would expect this is also what you would
expect but um
it's also perhaps the most demented
reaction this is from nancy pelosi
not you what she's saying here is not
unique and not the first time she said
something like this but here she is
fully embracing the religious cult-like
nature of
of of all of this and of the whole
quote-unquote anti-racism
movement um here she is appointing
george floyd a a christ-like messianic
figure who dies for the sins of
of all mankind or at least of of white
mankind um
here's here here she is thank you george
floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how
how heartbreaking was that call out for
your mom
i can't breathe but because of you and
because of
thousands millions of people around the
world who came
out for justice your name will always be
synonymous
with justice good lord you know what i
actually had not listened to that full
clip until right now because i could
barely stomach it
all i heard was thank you george george
floyd for sacrificing your life
sacrificing your life for all of us it's
not an exaggeration this this
is what christians say about jesus
christ
they've appointed george floyd their
their christ their messiah
in this religious cult which
which has the the hallmarks in every
sense of of a religion
as we've talked about original it has
there's always the concept of original
sin
um only we know in the christian faith
original sin is shared by everyone
um in this case it is uh it is a racial
original sin
white people have it we pass it down i
guess in our bloodline this guilt
but where she she says there your name
will always be
synonymous with justice
i you know every time i hear something
like that i
i can't help but but think to
and i don't even know her name or what
she looks like and that's the point
but but imagine being the woman who who
george floyd
robbed didn't just rob but it
forced his way into her house put a gun
to her and robbed her
another one of the guys in his crew
pistol whipped her
so you've just you you've been robbed
and pistol-whipped in your own home by
george floyd and his crew
that happened a few years ago and uh and
now you have to hear
nancy pelosi saying that his name is
synonymous with justice
imagine if the if the christ figure that
your culture has
selected is the guy who forced his way
into your home and robbed you
but no nobody cares about her her she is
literally nameless and faceless in
as far as the public and the public goes
uh one other clip to play this is maxine
waters
and i think there's a lesson we could
learn here maybe maybe even a little bit
of inspiration we can find here maxine
waters
we know is guilty of tampering with the
jury intimidating the jury
republicans tried to center her for for
it but uh
that that was voted down by ev every
democrat
in congress came to her defense and
then she went on on msnbc and continued
to refuse to apologize
and made herself into the victim but
let's listen to what she said
i'm just pleased uh that i still feel
strong enough and able enough
to go out with the young people and say
auntie maxine is here
and i support you and i want you to be
activist
i'm so sorry uh that it causes pain
oftentimes with my colleagues many times
they're in these districts
where they're frightened where they have
a lot of racism well they still haven't
moved to the point where they can have a
decent conversation
about these issues and sometimes it's
very difficult for them
but they stood up with me today they put
me at the center
because of my visit to minneapolis and
my colleagues stood with me
and they voted to table of the motion
that was put up to censor me because the
top the republicans love to use me as a
target
they raise money on my backs that's that
maxine waters
that black woman who is so uppity and uh
who is someone we can't control
and so you've got to make sure that i
have enough money
to keep her from getting re-elected and
i keep getting re-elected
and these poor people many of them
retirees they keep giving them their
money
they don't seem to understand they're
not going to get me out of office
i'm here until i decide to retire
i can't i mean all i did was fly from dc
to minneapolis and tamper intimidate
with a jury and intimidate them
to get to get a verdict that i want in a
local murder trial
clearly if they're if they would if
anyone would object to that the only
reason could possibly be racism
did she actually by the way did she
actually call herself auntie maxine
did i hear that right that what is that
how she referred to herself
if you want an argument for term limits
there it is right there
that person that clip right there is
everything you need to know
she considers herself to be the the
auntie to her constituents
refusing to leave how old is she now
like 98.
she said you're not i'm never leaving
i'm never leaving be here forever
because i know my constituents are
stupid enough to keep voting me in i've
never done anything for them
at all but the one lesson we could take
the one
maybe a bit of inspiration that we can
all take from auntie maxine
is um refusing to apologize
this is the left's game they're just
never ever going to apologize
for anything
i'm not going to apologize anyone who's
attacking me they're wrong
i'm the victim here really and we could
take
you know i don't the self-victimization
thing i can't stomach that when anyone
does it so we could take that part of it
out
but the part where you refuse to
apologize that has to be the move
that's what the left does it works
there's nothing to be gained by
apologizing
especially when your attackers are
totally disingenuous
now in this case the critics of maxine
waters are not disingenuous
like i'm one of the critics and i
actually am concerned about tampering
with
and and trying to influence a journey a
jury
but she refuses to apologize anyway and
that's that's we should all take
take notes from there we should take
that cue
all right actually one other one last
clip to play before we move on to
reading the comments this is greta
thunberg
um i don't know why i don't know the
context
i can't see any i can't imagine any
context that would
that would make this anything less than
absurd but she's she's instructing other
countries on how they should handle uh
the vaccine
distribution here she is just with the
climate crisis
those who are the most vulnerable need
to be prioritized
and global problems require global
solutions
it is completely unethical that
high-income countries
are now vaccinating young and healthy
people if that happens
at the expense of people in risk groups
and on the front lines in low and
middle-income countries
and this is a moral test we talked today
about showing solidarity
and yet vaccine nationalism it's what's
running the vaccine distribution
what who what do we care what she has to
say
who asked her opinion on vaccine
distribution
but going back to religious cult this is
a the left's a religious cult
and um many religions throughout history
have
child prophets child profits play a big
role in a lot of religions and
and that's what she is for left she's a
child prophet and she can she doesn't
have to have any expertise at all
now usually the move is like like she
can pontificate about anything and we're
supposed to listen
and that's been the case since she was
like 14 when she first stepped on the
stage
instructing telling the whole world of
countries other governments
what sort of policies they're supposed
to enact and for that we're supposed to
listen nobody's allowed to ask her
what is your even have a high school
diploma
why should we listen to you what's your
expertise
yet of course if you get up there as
just a normal
sane adult and say something like um
you know only men have penises if you
say that you're going to hear what are
you
since when did you become a doctor i
don't see your medical degree
that's the way that goes all right let's
move to reading the uh the youtube
comments
this is from banksparento says hi matt i
just wanted to
you to know how young some of your
listeners are i'm 12
and uh i listen to the show every day
well i appreciate that and um
there are a lot here's what i'll say for
this show
there are a lot worse things that a 12
year old could be watching on youtube
i don't know if that's the greatest
selling point but
that's what i'm going with sebastian
says your show was late today matt
usually i'm able to watch it during my
study hall period but you released it
during my science class
for that you are of course canceled well
i hate to say but you know what
you're probably going to hear better
science on this show than you'll hear in
your science class depending on where
you go to school
um another comment says the reason no
one is talking about the alien stuff
is there really isn't anything to talk
about other than pointing it out you're
right about there really only being two
options but in both
the only logical response seems to be
sit around and wait for a third
explanation or wait to be conquered and
try not to think about it until then
well yeah i if if there are aliens out
there that are visiting the planet
there's not a lot we could do about that
if there's another country that has this
otherworldly technology
uh that is so mind-blowing that that
even our
government officials think that it might
be from another planet in both those
cases probably not a lot we can do about
it all i'm saying is
that's the case for everything we talk
about it's not anything that we can
individually do about it any any big
societal issue
yeah we talk about everything we talk
about all these things
i would think that um the reason we
would talk about the alien issue is that
it is important
i don't know i would consider it
important and it's interesting
it's much more interesting and
fascinating than 95 percent of the stuff
we're talking
about all the time
but you know we ignore it um
let's see another comment says matt
could easily pass off as chauvin's
defense attorney check it out
i've seen a lot of comments like this
that i look like chauvin's defense
attorney why because we both have beards
all bearded guys look the same
that kind of bigotry is not allowed on
this show you are banned from the show
obviously
and finally it says matt the cosmos is
huge there's a statistical certainty
that there's intelligent life on another
planet
it's also statistical certainty that
such a planet is so far away from us
that we'll never know about them and
will never be able to reach them and
vice versa
yeah that use that used to be my
position and that's still
a very credible position there's a good
argument for that the distances are so
vast
the closest solar our neighboring solar
system like the one that's right next
door to us
in cosmic terms is i don't know 25
trillion
miles away four or five light years 25
trillion miles
uh we just with current technology would
take us centuries and centuries to get
there
and that's the closest one and imagine
it
it takes you centuries to get there and
you get there and there's nothing there
well it'll be another thousand years to
the next one um
so i used to think that that i used to
agree with that but then also
you're thinking of things in human terms
and some of these
vehicles these crafts that we've seen
videos of and
the pentagon has confirmed that these
are flying objects
and they're doing things that to us seem
impossible
and so when we talk about how long it
takes to travel across space
we are we are saying that based on
technology as we understand it
there might be technology out there that
can do things we can't understand we
know there are because we see them
but our government has seen that stuff
flying around in the sky and told us
about it
and then we all just yawn and move on
now a quick word from helix sleep
you know when you don't get a good
night's sleep it everyone knows it it's
obvious to you it's obvious to everyone
you're wearing it on your face you got
the bags under the eyes everything
it looks hideous um don't go out in
public looking like that that's why you
need a helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to make the perfect mattress
for you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back wherever you sleep
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and everybody's unique taste
you don't need to take their word for it
you can go to uh helix you know they
check out their their reviews helix was
awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020
by gq and wired magazine and uh you
could take my word for it too because
we have we got one we had one helix
sleep mattress and we just got a second
one uh
and that's that's true that's how much
we we enjoy these uh we have one my
daughter has one
the boys they don't have one yet they
you know they don't they don't
um they can just they can sleep on like
a cardboard box and they'd be fine
just go to helix sleep.com walsh take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders that's
walsh again helixsleep.com sleep dot com
slash walsh helix sleep dot com slash
walls for
200 off your mattress order well it's
almost time for another
new episode of candace this week's
special guest is dana white
and um always a lot of interesting
things to say you don't want to miss
that the show
streams on fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8
p.m central only on dailywire.com if
you're not a member yet
use code candace and get 25 off
and and don't forget also of course the
candace podcast which is available on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
your podcast now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to move away from issues
surrounding race and policing to talk
about issues surrounding race and
cartoon shows
no matter what as we've seen race is
involved in every issue it's involved
even when it's not involved though
sometimes when it is involved it's not
involved
like any time a white person is a victim
of interracial violence so
anyway i hope that clears things up now
the headline on yahoo news
which i promise is not satire reads as
follows
kids cartoon bluey criticized for not
having disabled queer
poor gender diverse or dogs of color
now apparently as we'll discover when we
keep reading bluey is an australian
children's show which is why i've never
heard of it
but even not being familiar with the
program it seems immediately clear that
the show
does have dogs of color i mean it has a
blue dog doesn't it
in fact all dogs are some kind of color
every dog is a dog of color just like
every person
is a person of color all people are some
kind of color aren't they
this is why the phrase people of color
is nonsensical and silly when applied
only to certain groups to the exclusion
of others like last i checked
caucasian people have a color
i can't imagine what a colorless person
would look like
they'd have to be translucent like some
kind of hideous
deep sea fish or something but certainly
again all
dogs have a color all dogs go to heaven
and all dogs have a color
uh that first part is not true at all in
my opinion despite what the cartoon
shows say
what can what can dog of color even mean
then does it mean that um
the show should have dogs which resemble
racial minorities
but wouldn't that be considered racist
if it did
none of this makes any sense in fairness
though we haven't read the article yet
maybe it will make a persuasive case you
know far be it for me to
make assumptions based merely on the
psychotic headline
so here's the article it says quote
the animated show for preschool children
follows bluey an anthropomorphic
six-year-old blue healer puppy
and her family as they go about life in
brisbane and
learn important life lessons in an
opinion piece on the abc
everyday website journalist beverly wang
shared her love of the hit cartoon
but also questioned why the show isn't
more representative wang asked why the
show which is set in the capital of
queensland
does not reflect the wide diversity of
the australian city
where are the disabled queer poor gender
diverse dogs of color and single-parent
dog families in bluey's bruised brisbane
she said if they're in the background
let them come forward
wang acknowledged the creators of bluey
may not view their show through a
political lens imagine that
but she argued it's important for
children's programming to be more
representative
she said the tender nuanced and joyful
show has already demonstrated depth and
range
in its ability to touch on important
issues quote as a parent of color i am
always conscious of the presence or
absence
of diverse representation in kids pop
culture what it means for children and
conversations we have around that wang
said
i sincerely believe you don't have to be
other
to think about this too okay well let me
say
as a translucent parent a parent without
color
a colorless parent um i am not conscious
at all
of the racial makeup of the cartoon
shows my kids watch
all of my kids have enjoyed peppa pig
for example
uh i have never wondered about the race
of peppa and her family they do seem
to be british but i never speculated
about their racial background
that's because they're pigs and also
fictional
that's also why i've never wondered
about the sexual orientation or gender
identity
of these fictional cartoon british pigs
i mean it's possible that daddy pig my
favorite character in the show
is in his private life a pansexual
gender fluid foot fetishist i mean it's
possible
the issue has simply never been
addressed in any episode of peppa pig
that i've ever watched
and i prefer in fact for the it not to
be addressed i prefer
daddy pig's sexual proclivities and even
his racial background
remain unexplored then again i'm i'm
approaching this from from the
perspective of a sane person
and that's why i often have so much
trouble relating to the concerns of the
left
now let's read a little more from the
article as it talks about
the mild blowback that the author wang
received for her psychotically insane
opinions
it says quote guardian australia's
political reporter amy remicus
said the amount of hate being directed
towards wang was the reason quote why
this country can never have a serious
conversation
she wrote on twitter the amount of hate
being directed at a journalist for a
very gentle piece
pointing out bluey is great but maybe it
doesn't represent everyone and is
something to think about
is why this country can never have a
serious con conversation
she continued quote you might not see
yourself or your family represented all
the time but if you're white
able-bodied and working slash middle
class you're not short of options
okay two quick points here
uh first i agree that we can't have
serious conversations but it's precisely
because
this kind of conversation racial
representation in a cartoon show about
fictional dogs
drowns out the serious conversation
this isn't the serious conversation we
need to have it's the unserious
conversation
that we're having instead second um
part of the whole point of a children's
show is for children to use their
imagination
they see themselves in these stories and
in these characters
through their imaginative faculties you
don't need to spoon feed it to them
the idea of representation actually
limits representation in a certain way
okay so if you say to a black child hey
look this dog is the representative for
black people that's your dog
you can see yourself in that dog when
you say that you've
limited the child never mind the as
noted rather dicey proposition of how
exactly you represent a human race in a
dog
the even bigger issue is that you've
limited the children in the audience
you're saying to the black children
here's your character and to the asian
children
here's yours and so on and so on
and the white kids you don't need one
but what children really want to do
and what they're very good at doing if
you let them is to relate to
and see themselves in any and all
characters
that's also how they learn empathy
you know they don't see the world
through the lens of racial identity
unless you
force them to and the great tragedy
right now is that we are
forcing them to instead of letting them
be individuals we're forcing them to see
themselves
as nothing but representatives of their
racial category
it's perverse it's dehumanizing
it causes racism it causes a lack of
empathy
it doesn't solve those problems it
causes it
and that after all is the whole point
and it's why beverly wang and anyone
else complaining about representation
and cartoon shows for children
is canceled
and daddy pig is cancelled too if he
really is
a pansexual foot fetishist can't have
any of that
in my cartoon shows and we'll leave it
there thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel valdoski the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the george floyd jurors saved themselves
the president and joe biden celebrate
the verdict
and more drag bar perverts throw money
at kids check it out on the michael
knowles show